bringing Sam Elliot in Sam le I'm gonna
think you're you're a lady boyfriend no
he's on caffeine
hello Santa morning how are you have a
seat
how you doing my name is Sam as well but
it's Sam Roberts sit down we're we're on
we're live some people get confused when
they come in yeah see I always think
that I always think that it's very clear
that we're doing a show because why else
what are we talking into this and
wearing these but people come in all the
time and they're like what are we on the
air right now in a whisper yeah they
have no idea and they start talking
about things that they shouldn't talk
about like you know little problems
they're having and we're not going to
tell them it's like you said on the air
or so if you want to just you know split
I said it's fun to watch good morning
good morning why thank you how are you
how are you doing this tell me is
getting a grave reviews but you're
promoted I'm a little fuzzy this morning
but why if I they hosted that with the
writers and the director last night you
get party where we had a nice meal had a
couple of drinks
Oh cocktails we've been on this road for
a long time and what time you get to get
to know good it wasn't bad you know good
up about the six are you at a place in
your career where you can say hey I want
a later call time like I won't go before
whatever time no I mean that I don't
even thank you at least I don't I don't
anticipate ever reaching the point where
I'm going to try to say I'm not going to
show up until next time other guys I do
that I was suppose there would do that
their careers probably tend to be
short-lived because if they're not
making a lot of money and they're making
demands like that I can't imagine
anybody would put up with that I can't
imagine anybody putting up with it today
you know it I think there maybe that
happened back in the day but yeah I just
think it's a V Lynaugh moves money it is
yeah yeah I guess I'd figure so I
certainly guys who have been around for
a long time I think sometimes I don't
wanna get up at five o'clock in the
morning anymore I that's what I would do
but I'm not in a position to do this you
I get up at the Kraken on a driver hour
I'm doing the show on Netflix and I'm
forever like I happened
an hour and a half one way to just to
get there every day so the five days a
week so why are you saying nothing
literally pardon why are you staying
closer to where you're shooting because
we like to go home and look all you do
yeah you want those guys who like to
just be in your own bed yeah well yeah I
just like to be home no this certain guy
that would fly home after gigs - I've
heard of guys like that that would would
do like I said Alan Alda when he's doing
mash every weekend would fly back from
California just to do with his wife
he'll deliver yeah I get that like I
said I'm less if normal shows where I've
been married for 33 years
you like being mad at Kevin I've been
together 39 we've been married 33 years
I do like it and you but you didn't it's
funny because you were both in Butch
Cassidy and you had like a she was but I
was like a fly on the wall
he never they fight I was literally a
shadow on the wall I had one liner it
was off-camera oh yeah line up take to
the curd good oh okay I'm the beginning
of the zoo who we didn't seem again
Redford was there and Newman walked into
it yeah and a couple of other guys that
I can't remember who they were you know
there were a couple of other flies on
the wall
yeah what a cool first scene is it is
cool yeah were you annoyed that were you
disappointed when you saw it you realize
not at all
you know I mean it was I was a contract
player thoughts it's the only reason I'm
listed on the credits is because I was
under contract to the studio solid card
player number two that's great
how did that work so you're your
accountant you were a contract player at
Fox is that like you just signed on to a
certain number of movies or whatever Fox
just needs people in you know they just
sign you on period just and then they do
what they want with you yeah I was paid
$85 a week and my rent that I was paying
at the time was $85 a month I lived
right up the back gate of Fox and
probably the best period or one of the
best periods of the game because I was
finally making a living as an actor you
know did you appreciate it back then
when you finally start making your
living saying this is what I'm doing now
is now I'm writing of course I mean
that's what I say it was one
exciting times for me I wanted to do
this since I was a kid there was you
know show business it's real now you
know it was exciting do you miss those
days of because they don't really do
that a contract thing that's over with I
was there left two years of that program
at Fox and they had one other program
that was a lot more substantial in that
the people that the kids that were under
contract did work a lot there that
didn't work a lot of Fox but the
programming Universal continued on for a
couple more years
the Fox program is coming to a close do
you like that better because you know
you're going to get a check or do you
like that now you're kind of I don't
know what the next job is going to be
but I'm going this yeah I think that you
know the security of a steady job is
always a great thing for an actor but
the uncertainty of it is also pleasing
in some way yeah how long was your
contract before if you had a contract
like your your contract about it is it
once a year or they keep you there's a
seven-year term contract Wow
options of the only on the studio said
they can turn you loose any time they
want
Wow fairly very one-sided absolutely
one-sided deal the only thing that's
similar to that now though is like all
these superhero movies like now they are
contracting the big stars to like seven
eight nine ten movies because they just
keep pumping them out pumping them out
popping them out
it all sucks yeah yeah that's just
another goal you wouldn't want to be in
a franchise delica you know you got two
or three more great big gigs coming up
I'm going to say you know I've learned
and never say never and but that doesn't
really interest me
yeah after almost 49 years in this
business I can't imagine getting
involved and franchises fighting being
literally I'd rather you know it's about
what's on the page to me yeah and you
know I'm not that I'm not saying I'm a
serious actor but it's it's really about
what's on the page and it's not about
making money it's never been about
making money for me and it's really been
about having a career yeah you said you
never did things that you feel good that
you've never done things just for money
so you kind of like all the projects
you've yeah
I mean early on you know there was a
time where it was like you know
certainly in the beginning but after I
left Fox you know and I was looking for
work and you know money and that was an
issue and you know the part of it that
after that I always figured it I was
going to have longevity in my career
that I better be careful how I quote
unquote expose myself you know it's
interesting isn't in the in the hero in
the movie you play an actor who you know
he's got one of his kind of come to
Jesus with himself things where he
admits that he's been making movies for
40 years or whatever but he's only proud
of one movie that he's ever made is that
a does that happen a lot these days I
thought there's that there's that about
the show and I always kind of wondered
about is that really possible that
somebody was known for one film any
lines and adapters and been around that
long
yeah and suppose these guys that have a
one it's almost like they say like
Timothy Hutton did ordinary people you
know and he wins the Oscar for Newsbeat
special Raging Bull and and then like
ever he's a great actor but he hasn't
done anything on that level
since then and they say it's almost a
jinx if you win something a little bit a
lot of people who have heard say that
maybe it's true yes
becomes your pinnacle and it becomes
kind of just nothing else II know
compared to Italy so that's what that's
what let go was saying yesterday John
Lithgow was in here and he was saying
that like one of his worries when he did
the series third Rock was that he never
wanted to do a series because for a
character actor that can be like the
kiss of death because now you're you're
tightly into that spot like that is your
role for forever which is never where
you want to be grew
you must've been excited when the when
this project the hero came across your
your your doorstep because you're in
every scene of this but this is your
yeah yeah you're gonna get real sick of
me if you watch this right I work for
Brett Haley on another film two years
ago caught I'll see you in my dreams
Brett's illinit director
and wrote and edited he wrote with his
writing partner mark - they're both
Brooklyn boys I worked with him on this
other film and during the course of
marketing the film Brett and I traveled
together and got to know each other
really well and and have a lot of regard
for each other and as we get to me for
whatever reason he sat down with bash
and wrote this script and it's like like
he said I'm on every page of it exactly
healing night and he wrote it for me I
cannot have had parts written for me
over the years but I've never had a
screenplay and entire screenplay written
for me pretty incredible have you ever
looked at a part that was written for
you like in the years past and like you
know was written for you you look at it
yeah I can't do that know that now I
make most of the parts that were for
sure written for me that I knew were
written for me fully embrace them I did
a song called The Big Lebowski a few
hours back the Coen brothers wrote my
part for me my name was in the script so
you know I didn't look at that and think
oh yeah not that one no that wasn't good
one can it be tough for you like you've
worked with so many great directors you
know what I mean you've done so much
stuff and like the director on here or
like the Coen brothers like you've
worked with a lot of great people
does it get tough when you get to a set
and you realize the director is not up
to snuff as compared to you know any
other coach everywhere kruseman there it
is this is fine and I like to think that
I go in with something in mind but it's
always nice to have a director that has
something in mind there so is that what
is that regular work for the director
that's what it's my game so that's what
gives you pause when you get there is
that if the director doesn't have a
vision behind what's going on then
you're like what what are we doing here
yeah yeah that's like a real almost lack
of ego like saying like I work like I
want to serve the director I want to
serve what's on the page that's a pretty
humble attitude to have about what
you're doing I just think that's where I
would be you know
look at myself one of the crew you know
always likened it to you know being on a
sailing ship and the guy standing Helms
the director you know I'm pulling the
sheets you know pulling the lines you
want you go the other way and I know
what are the people that go the other
way but that's just my game have you
seen people mistreat directors and yeah
different people mistreat everybody on
this earth you have right and is it
uncomfortable to watch your dream you
know there's you pull people aside at
this point and be like what's [ __ ] you
doing dude absurd the food cooks really
coarse how they respond to it did with a
Simon some of them walk away in a huff
and some of them would embrace it and
get it Sam Elliot as a presence as the
voice it's just yeah that you the the
unis of you will use that if if you I
feel like if you were to grab especially
a young actor I was like what the [ __ ]
are you doing here you probably get
through it's usually a young one is it
really
wait they haven't been to enough where
they think what are they doing they're
being like they're coming late or there
there are they later or [ __ ] in
their trailer that kind of stuff or just
attitude it's really mostly attitude
where they haven't gone long enough to
be humbled I think properly like they
still they they're the ones who would
walk in with that ego right I think it's
entitlement or something like that or
lack of do you think when you look back
because people talk about that like
generationally about Millennials or
whatever but when you look back at
yourself as a young actor do you think
you had some of that in you that it had
to get knocked out of you know you think
you started with the right head on your
shoulders I think it was raised right
and then I got to the pill it was ready
to do it rang right I mean my dad
wouldn't put up with that [ __ ] you also
talked to him at one point about like
you thought you almost screwed yourself
because you're very you're opinionated
and you kind of speak you're modest
opinionated and very smart yes certainly
is but it is something that you you just
embraced about yourself or do you kind
of go like okay I have to learn how to
I'd say this at this time I'd still I
don't know I think I'm more mindful of
it today but you know what the [ __ ] it
is what it is you know as you say what
you say and sometimes you regret it but
you know I like being honest and
opinionated well I get that almost got
you in trouble
way that way that way it was it was in
regard to a film called lifeguard that I
did in 1974 and it was in regard to the
way they marketed the film you know the
shoulder like beach blanket bingo and
you know the one sheet was an animated
one she was me and a pair of Speedos
with a big busted girl in either arm and
I said every girl's summer dream over it
and it was like wow it was really
something that was a little more serious
to those of us that were making the film
meaning the writer the director and
myself and the producer as well but when
paramount send me out on the road to
market the film that's been like six
weeks in the road and you know
invariably I'd go in the towns and get
into these interviews with reviewers and
you know people that were touting the
film and they'd open up you know they'd
seen the film and they'd had the you
know the marketing package that looked
at that and they'd open up these
interviews invariably with this movie
isn't anything like I expected it to be
and that just opened it up for me and I
said yeah no [ __ ] and then go off on the
advertising campaign I don't work for
Paramount for 25 years after all that's
right not that I was blacklisted or
anything and maybe it was just the way
it was you know who knows he paid for it
out there maybe yes but it better thing
it on some level it's a good thing that
you mentioned Timothy you know but you
know not that I would have wanted
Academy Award I'm not saying that but if
career would have come then in 74 you
know I just assumed it's happening the
way it's happening now rather than back
yeah I mean like the trajectory of the
whole thing that you would imagine that
if you would hit your super successful
point then do you know how do you how do
you maintain that yeah I don't think you
maintain it and I don't think probably
as a young actor whether you're male or
female it's you know that's a lot to
recommend I think that's kind of what's
what's the toughest part is it new money
is it Fame is it attention is it just
the workload the toughest part to deal
with yeah like what what what what do
you think you know screws people off
course eventually I don't know I think
when you hear all the time how wonderful
you are that is you know not a good
thing right very nice we've never been
in that position we should be doing it
yeah and it's also [ __ ] and you know
some people were normal depends on are
you talking about I guess but there's a
lot of lip service probably along the
way that people say things they don't
mean because imagine yeah and then all
these all these people that were
complimenting you is when the money
starts to dry up all the compliments go
away and that crazy high you were just
on becomes this you know it's a heady
deal it's a yeah heady deal you know
it's like you know I'm in the middle of
this press tour and you know I've got
people traveling with me that called
years along the way and take care of you
know I love them for that you know
you're going to these situations you
don't know anybody and everything you
know everybody knows who you are either
because of you know they literally know
they are because they've followed your
career or they've just read a bio on you
the bio on the film and pretend they
know who they are but you know it's that
recognition thing I think is the hardest
thing for an actor or at least for me to
deal with and I guess you can't figure
out what's real right like what's a real
connection and what somebody just like
trying to get close to success yeah
success is a weird thing there is a
theory in the in the film about this
movie was called iceberg when it was in
treatment for him when it first came to
him in which is a title I really loved
and we'll always be sorry that they
changed it on some level but the theory
is is that success is like an iceberg
you know it said that eight of it or
however whatever percentage of an
iceberg is above the you know writing
the level of the sea and that's what you
see but the real [ __ ] is underneath you
know act and that's that's the step that
holds up the part you see it's an
interesting theory okay all right go
ahead
do you people around you who are able to
tell you when you're wrong like a lot of
people don't have anybody in their life
we'll just at times go shut your face
like we really need that ya know I have
definitely have people in my life that
do that my wife has comes to mind first
is she comfortable saying that yeah
especially when I left town came back
here to just keep everything in
perspective yeah you know in that that's
really the truth that's that was good
advice as you can good it seems like in
the movie that's the that your character
kind of hits that spot went well when
he's on drugs but when he when he's
accepting the Lifetime Achievement Award
from the little Western society mmm and
he's kind of looking at the award and
he's looking at and he's like I didn't
even everybody know I think one Dahlia
like is really uncomfortable with that
recognition and you know I'm not sure
I've had that this script is so well
written in terms of what's real for me
that you know that in that speech that
he guess playing its that Lifetime
Achievement or you know and whatever he
says is that's really the right it's
really right he's not sure that he's any
more deserving of it than anyone else
right right which is a healthy
perspective I think to have it's a weird
thing because you think about like well
all these opportunities that I got if
somebody else had gotten the same
opportunities they probably would have
also been able to succeed at it so why
am i up here getting a trophy for it
yeah you know there's so many people in
the movie business that are so much more
talented
that'll never get a shot yeah I mean the
elusiveness in the whole game you know
in certainty is in more show today you
know with this fascination of celebrity
you know that that's you know I mean
there's always been quote-unquote
celebrities but this fascination with it
in our society today and in the world
today maybe is just Amen I don't know
we're really kind of really wrecking
with that as a country right now aren't
we yeah well you guys you guys hit that
too celebrity culture when when TMZ
starts to get involved in the paparazzi
because I mean you know better than most
people how much the paparazzi game has
changed
you know you know in the last several
over the course of decades yeah that's
weird that's weird it's like it's like
these guys that are around and gals
there's a few of them around town that
like are dogging us on this tour and
they've got a stack of photos with it
means you know some of them it's like
genuinely they play and they may be a
fan or something but it's like you know
they're not looking to stick them in a
book or put them on their wall and
they're gonna put them into the
marketplace you know it's like really
when you're signing a photo yeah form
you're like I don't think this is for
your collected a stock photo and they
have the marker ready it's not like to
anybody right yeah do you want me to
make this out to
oh no no no no there was a scene in the
film that we ended up bred into that
cutting out Brett Haley also edits he
writes edits and directs and there was a
scene in the film which some fan came
and knocked on his window and everyone
leave was sitting in there lit up a
joint in this guy it was right after the
diagnosis in the top of the film
he's got knocks on the phone he praises
him tells you enough wonderful is asked
him to sign this photo and Lee didn't
really want to deal with him but the guy
says please Ben here the pastor that's
like coolest and joy signs and then the
guy pulls out another one
and then Lee says he's not going to sign
it and that guy goes off on him you guys
hope you die and then you got to go on
the internet right the road and let the
world know it's a big business now I
mean you know actually if you can reach
that fascination with celebrity lock in
a road you know and it's like what
really you don't have any fascination
with I guess just you know I do I mean I
have a fascination with people you know
like you know when I'm doing this thing
called a star born right now
you know I first went met Bradley Cooper
it was you know I'm much younger man
than I am
and it and a much more dynamic man than
I am
and most impressive up close that was
like wow you know this guy's like
amazing and then getting to the set and
being around Stephanie Lady Gaga's to
Sherry you know it's like a little
unsettling cuz all I knew about her was
Lady Gaga
you know how was she on second she is
I'm invertible she was unbelievable Yeah
right you're wonderful woman and she's
an incredible actress and you know
you're either Gaga fan or not I'm a huge
goes as we are yeah were you within
going in or was that one of those things
like I'm not sure or delino going in
this girl and Bradley both that that's
one of the reasons that I loved both of
them dearly as they've got this
incredible work ethic dances those are
the people who deserve to be on top so
you're excited about stars born I think
it's going to be good
what we and also drew group yeah do you
know when you go into these situations
like as much as you're like why this
Bradley Cooper's amazing and she's
amazing they look at you and then
they're very well aware of your work -
oh yeah they're probably watching you
for a long time do you feel that coming
back from them or are you removing that
no really is a look like a mutual
respect thing you know I mean that's
part of their greatness you know they'll
be little get it back we're good people
right do you stay close to people after
a film wraps because it becomes like a
little family Muslim sir with just fade
away
the [ __ ] gypsies man it is right it's
really weird and you think you're going
there I've never seen sure once Wow
since masks a little I was 83 84 is a
long time ago somewhere Berkeley did you
guys have a as you get along when you're
saying it like you were great friends
we're making it and then once it's over
it's just you go on with your life
you've got lives that take you away and
everybody on the outside of that world
thinks that we're all like in tight with
each other you know it's just not the
case it's just the nature of the beast
I feel like I fight so hard I'd be like
oh I can be Cher's friend now I got your
shows in it no I'm going to try to go
see her actually she's going to be in
Vegas Paul I'm gonna make every effort
to go see Aaron November yeah that's a
long time you know see how about our
extols did you stay with him or talk
about me and Erik a couple of times over
the years but rarely did you say extra
murmur for I'm sorry did you stay in
touch with Patrick Swayze after you guys
uh not not a lot not ran into him you
know but it's just you have different
circles and different circles of friends
Catherine I live at Malibu we've been
out there for four years and you know
it's a hell of a long way out of
Hollywood you know there's people in
that community out there we hear her in
the movie business but don't hang with
him yeah I just was you don't really
have any active right oh yeah I've got a
couple yeah Nick Offerman's a dear
friend how is he you know he's great
Emily he's incredible and everything he
does is just the best good you like
being grounded and just hanging with
real people sometimes where people out
of it and I think it's important I think
it's important to have a life outside of
the game you know like I said before
it's a heady you know I mean we all
think we're so [ __ ] wonderful in the
movie you know
do you go to like the award shows the
Oscar isn't stuff like that
a bin once well you got the Golden
Globes a lot back when I first got into
the business I used to go a lot more of
those award shows I've been to the Emmys
a couple of times been in the Golden
Globes the number of times been to the
Oscars once
what do you member what you always know
did you not want to go back or did
nothing for you is it too overwhelming
yeah it's like a party that if you're
not invited to be there then when are
you gonna see it better on the tube at
home yeah yeah I mean it sounds
incredible to be there with with that
crowd there's no question about it but
again this whole fascination with the
celebrity thing is kind of really the
red carpet oh yeah you don't do you like
doing that when you have a film that
you're in your oh you do like a course
because when you got a reason to be
there
you don't like you showing up and
putting your face at going hi it's me if
there's no reason yeah no no I get that
we had a laura Prepon in here yesterday
no and she was talking about you Bruce
yeah you got the kisser yeah yeah she
was just cool she was talking about the
chemistry that you guys had yeah kind of
instantly were you worried at all about
that because when you're making this
movie and she and you know did this age
difference is there the chemistry isn't
there it screws up the story right yeah
but I never once was worried about it
one of the things it was great about
this thing is when we started out and
went out to the different actors it was
like there was no list of actors for any
part they were all first choices
including Laura and you know I mean I
didn't know Laura I'd never crossed
paths with T or Christian knew my wife
and then you offer them but I met Laura
relevant and a little more backstory had
I never was a fan of the 70s show but if
I was swimming around in the TV back in
those days and I saw that redhead I was
always intrigued by her I thought she
you know she had a brain
amongst all these kind of mindless
characters nothing personal about
shopping economies I think I'm not yet
but Laura always fascinated me and when
I started watching oranges in the black
and seeing her work there and I don't
know about the week two weeks before we
started on the hero she showed up on the
side of the ranch to see Ashton and
Daniel and that was my first encounter
with her and I just told her right then
I said man we're gonna [ __ ] make some
fireworks on this thing because I just
knew that we were going to yeah in that
first scene where she walked into that
scene we're offering offering are
smoking dope yeah she just stopped it
cold and I mean that the first moment
she's got and she says hi it sounds like
it does work it really it really what
struck me the rest of the film to get
over it a fun job you have again you end
up falling in love with these people
because I would have been like I'm level
you fall in love with and doesn't matter
if it's a male-female and it's just it's
just I don't know the exchange that goes
on yeah it's so personal sometimes then
it's just you can't help but be
attracted or maybe repelled by whoever
it is you know but with Laura it was
like how you Schmidt Marie on how do you
break that yet at the end I wonder
because I'm a married guy too and like
in the end it's you know it's go home
this is one of the reasons I like to go
home you know i sat right in that
fantasy world yeah you know I mean it's
acting's acting you know it's not me up
there it's you know that's what I do
it's not who I am does it ever linger
though like the feelings for a person
whatever it is like like after the you
done shooting is ever like [ __ ] them
sometimes or you know I mean it's hard
to you know the separation period might
be a little longer a be so tough for me
to get over it you gotta you know right
is it didn't look at Laura Ben
and we're having a kid I mean she's
eight months pregnant even more
beautiful than she was when she was
working on the pill
we both said the same thing she looks
amazing pregnant she's unbelievable
yeah and you and we have to rap with you
they're telling us so let's just the
hero is in theaters today everyone is
saying this is an amazing performance by
and any good will be the voice bye bye
opens with Angelica the United orders
that bling consider okay yeah okay I'm
not sure if you know orders yeah an
inbred Haley the director and I are
gonna both be doing Q&A as to this oh
you are at all cool this'll be fun so
free in New York I see the Lincoln
Center and if you're not Angelica yeah
or if you're not if it's not look it up
google it it's called the hero Sam
Elliot and if it doesn't end up playing
in a town near you get it digitally I'm
sure it will come out soon implement or
be good for to the paper there it is
find it it's worth finding and it's a
it's a film that Sam Elliott is proud of
so it's got to be good I enjoyed it very
much thank you sir thank you buddy hooks
was mad with you good yeah we'll be
right back thank you